ALICIA.
>> Alicia: BRYAN LLENAS IN
NEW YORK, THANK YOU.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI ADMITTING OVER
THE WEEKEND HE MOVED TO THE
GOALPOSTS ON THE NUMBERS NEEDED
FOR COVID HERD IMMUNITY.
WATCH.
>> I WOULD IMAGINE THAT YOU
WOULD NEED SOMETHING A LITTLE
LESS THAN THE 90%.
THAT’S WHERE I GOT TO THE 85.
BOTTOM LINE IS IT IS A
GUESSTIMATE.
I GAVE ARRANGED, AND I USE ANY
DISCUSSION LIKE WE ARE HAVING
NOW, DANA, TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO GET TO THAT GOAL OF 70-85% OF
THE PEOPLE VACCINATED.
THAT’S WHERE WE REALLY WANT TO
BE.
>> Alicia: JOINING ME NOW IS
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND MEDIA
POLITICS CALMNESS FOR THE HILL
JOE CONCHA.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE ON THIS
MONDAY.
YOU JUST HEARD DR. FAUCI, WHAT
IS YOUR TAKE AWAY FROM THAT?
>> I THINK THAT DR. FAUCI NEEDS
TO BE MORE CAREFUL WITH HIS
LANGUAGE PAID WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT GUESSTIMATES.
GOOD START SAYING THAT YOU
DELIBERATELY MOVE TO THE
GOALPOSTS.
YOU ARE NO LONGER THE TOP
INFECTIOUS DISEASE DOCTOR IN THE
U.S. WORKING OFF THE DATA AND
WORKING OFF THE SCIENCE.
YOU ARE NOW JUST ANOTHER GUY ON
TV THROWING DARTS.
AND I THINK THAT DR. FAUCI NEEDS
TO TEMPER HIS A MEDIA APPETITE.
HE DOES NOT HAVE TO SAY YES TO
EVERY INTERVIEW.
THAT’S NOT TO SAY THAT YOU
SHOULD NOT DO INTERVIEWS AT ALL,
BUT UNLESS HE HAS SOMETHING
ESSENTIAL TO SAY HE DOES NOT
HAVE TO GO ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION AND TALK ABOUT
GUESSTIMATES.
THAT DOES NOT INSPIRE CONFIDENCE
FROM PEOPLE THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE ON THE FENCE IN TERMS OF
TAKING THE VACCINE.
AND ALSO DR. FAUCI CAN LEARN TO
SAY I DON’T KNOW SOMETIMES.
BECAUSE THIS IS A NOVEL VIRUS.
IT IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION.
SOMETIMES WE DON’T KNOW WHAT WE
DON’T KNOW AND INSTEAD HE SPEAKS
WITH SUCH CERTITUDE LIKE SAYING
THAT THE VACCINE WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE IN VIRTUALLY
GUARANTEED UNTIL MANY MONTHS
INTO 2021, AND HERE WE ARE A TWO
COMPANY IS ALREADY DISTURBING
NOT VACCINE.
SO IN THE END, DR. FAUCI DOES A
TREMENDOUS SERVICE TO THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT HE IS NOT PERFECT.
IT’S OKAY TO CRITICIZE HIM ONCE
IN A WHILE, BECAUSE HE TOO CAN
GET IT WRONG.
>> Alicia: HE DID RECEIVE SOME
CRITICISM FROM MARCO RUBIO ON
TWITTER.
HE WRITES "WHO DR. FAUCI LIED
ABOUT MASKS IN MARCH.
DR. FAUCI HAS BEEN DISTORTING
THE LEVEL FOR HERD IMMUNITY.
NOT JUST HIM, MANY ELITE BUBBLES
BELIEVED THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
DOES NOT KNOW WHAT IS GOOD FOR
THEM, SO THEY NEED TO BE TRICKED
INTO DOING THE RIGHT THING.
MY QUESTION IS, IF THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE SAID FOR
LEARNING AS WE GO, AS YOU SAID,
IT IS A NOVEL CORONAVIRUS.
EVEN THE TOP EXPERTS IN THE
WORLD HAD TO LEARN SOME WAY OR
ALONG THE WAY.
>> OH, SURE, THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SAID WHAT DR. FAUCI
SAID.
THE SURGEON GENERAL SAID THAT
MASTS WEREN’T NECESSARY IN
MARCH.
DR. FAUCI CLARIFIED WITHOUT
APOLOGIZING, BUT DID SAY, I WAS
ONLY SAYING THAT BECAUSE I
WANTED TO PROTECT FRONTLINE
MEDICAL WORKERS AND NOT WANT A
RUN ON MASKS, THAT’S WHY SAID
THAT.
BUT WHEN YOU SEE THESE THINGS
AND THEN LATER MOVE THE
GOALPOSTS OR HAVE TO CORRECT
THINGS AFTER A WHILE, PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE AS YOU SAID AN
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION GETS
MORE SHAKY.
SO YES, WE CAN LEARN AS WE GO.
AND FOR RIGHT NOW EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE TWO VACCINES AND WE ARE TEN
MONTHS INTO THIS THING, WE STILL
DON’T KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS
DISEASE OTHERWISE WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO EXPLAIN WHY CALIFORNIA
AND THE LOCKDOWN HAS EXPLODING
CASES IN FLORIDA WHICH IS
RELATIVELY OPEN IS IN DOING
RELATIVELY AS BADLY.
SO WE ARE STILL LEARNING,
ALICIA.
NO QUESTION.
>> Alicia: I WANT TO MOVE ON
TO SOMETHING HERE, BECAUSE THE
ONGOING BATTLE BETWEEN CNN AND
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION JUST
SAW ONE MORE BLOW-BY-BLOW THIS
PAST WEEKEND.
TAKE A LISTEN TO JAKE TAPPER.
>> THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT
ARE JUST SO MENDACIOUS, I WOULD
NOT PUT THEM ON ERROR.
KAYLEIGH McENANY, I NEVER
BOOKED HER.
JASON MILLER FROM THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
I WOULD NEVER BOOK HIM.
THESE ARE JUST PEOPLE WHO TELL
LIES IN A WAY THAT MOST PEOPLE
BREATHE.
AND THERE IS NO VALUE IN THAT.
>> Alicia: KAYLEIGH McENANY
KAYLEIGH McENANY --
KAYLEIGH McENANY DID RESPOND
ON TWITTER.
HERE’S WHAT SHE WROTE.
THIS IS A THERAPY SESSION FOR A
BROKEN NETWORK AND JAKE TAPPER
IS LAZY ENOUGH TO PARTICIPATE BY
LOBBYING BASELESS PERSONAL
ATTACKS WITH ZERO EVIDENCE.
JAKE’S REAL PROBLEM, I DO NOT
LEAK, I DO NOT LIE, BUT I DO
CALL OUT THE LIVES OF THE MEDIA,
I.E. CNN, RUSSIA COLLUSION HOAX.
A JOKE, WE ARE WEEKS AWAY FROM A
NEW ADMINISTRATION AND THEY ARE
JUST GOING TO WALK OUT THE DOOR
AND EVERYONE IS STILL GOING TO
BE THROWING PUNCHES?
>> I’M NOT UNDERSTANDING THIS,
CNN HIRED KAYLEIGH McENANY AS
POLITICAL ANALYSTS BEFORE SHE
WAS WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
AND I IMAGINE THAT’S BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZED HER PERSPECTIVE
AND DID NOT THINK SHE HAD A
PROBLEM WITH THE TRUTH.
TO THE BOTTOM LINE I WILL LEAVE
IT HERE, JAKE TAPPER USE TO A
BOOK MICHAEL AVENATTI PERSONALLY